few actors ever have a year like Charlie
Sheen did in 1986 especially when
they're only 21 years old that was the
year that he added platoon Ferris
Bueller's Day Off Lucas and a little
Indie sci-fi movie called The Wraith to
his growing filmography he was only the
top build star in the last one but
unfortunately it's the least remembered
of the four in The Wraith Sheen plays
the titular character who is both the
ghost of a murdered teen and a different
kid who's new to town sound confusing
Not only would explaining further ruin
the movie but it also doesn't do the
admittedly convoluted plots any favors
trying to boil it down to a single
sentence convoluted isn't necessarily
bad though and The Wraith does tell a
pretty interesting story with a few
surprising twists but the biggest reason
to check it out is that it presents one
of the coolest and most underrated
anti-heroes of that era sci-fi not to
mention that every scene of the movie
absolutely drips with the mid-1980s cool
especially the awesome version of a
Dodge m4s turbo Interceptor that The
Wraith uses as both transportation and
weapon